we are here right now
arrived at the federal election office in Wiesbaden,
have almost 5,000
certified supporting signatures in the luggage.
we now give them to the AB test,
so that we can vote for the European election on 09.06
be admitted.
at this point we would like to meet again at really
Thank you all,
who signed for us,
who have done advertising for us.
only through your help we can do it
hopefully to come to the European Parliament,
us for it our topics for people,
Environment and animals to use.
that's why big,
big thank you to all of you and uh,
we now continue to take the momentum,
because we also need you all
now quite active in the election campaign,
when posterging,
standing,
distribute at the flyer,
talking to friends,
s,
relatives.
now it's really getting started!